-Our next guest is heading
on tour
with Taylor Swift next year.
Performing "The Perfect Pair"
from her album "Beatopia,"
give it up for beabadoobee!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ You ought to know that ♪
♪ I think we're one
and the same ♪
♪ I don't think
we could help it ♪
♪ No, I don't think
♪ We don't talk much ♪
♪ Guess 'cause
nothing has changed ♪
♪ And I'm not sure I like it ♪
♪ And I'm so tired of fighting ♪
♪ If I told you,
you know how to ♪
♪ Go and break my heart in two ♪
♪ 'Cause I would anyways ♪
♪ We'd end up like always ♪
♪ You know me,
you better show me ♪
♪ That you can say it
to my face ♪
♪ 'Cause you know
we're the same ♪
♪ There's worse things
I can take ♪
♪♪
♪ I know you hate it ♪
♪ When there's nothing to say ♪
♪ I'm not quite sure
we'd fix it ♪
♪ Guess we're so used to it ♪
♪ Wish I had known this ♪
♪ From the beginning ♪
♪ We find it hard to work out ♪
♪ Why we have all this doubt ♪
♪ If I told you,
you know how to ♪
♪ Go and break my heart in two ♪
♪ 'Cause I would anyways ♪
♪ We'd end up like always ♪
♪ You know me,
you better show me ♪
♪ That you can say it
to my face ♪
♪ 'Cause you know
we're the same ♪
♪ There's worse things
I can take ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]